- Hey, it's your buddy Zach.
Tomorrow's Thanksgiving, I'm in New York,
and I'm going to see if
a stranger will invite me
to their Thanksgiving dinner.
Let's go.
What are your plans for Thanksgiving?
- We're actually going to
my sister's in Westport.
- Spending it with my
family, watch football.
- Do you think I could come?
Would you let me come to dinner?
- For sure.
- Really?
- Yeah, I mean, I guess you could come.
- We won't mind.
- Yeah, you're in, man!
- So this is real, you're
willing to let me come over?
- Yeah, sure!
- Okay, do you want to hold this?
- I have a pen somewhere, sorry.
- So give me your address or number,
however best to reach you.
- Okay, here's my number.
- Great!
- Yeah.
- So we'll meet you at the
Westport train station.
- Sounds like you're trying to ditch me.
- No!
- Alright, so I'm going
to call your number
just to make sure.
Is that a three oh?
- Yeah, is that you?
- That's me!
- Son of a gun!
- Do you want me to bring anything?
- No, bring yourself!
- Just yourself.
- No food?
- We'll have food for you.
- Great.
This is going great.
This is better than I
ever could have expected.
So far everyone has said yes,
I can come to their Thanksgiving dinner,
which is awesome but
also a little surprising.
We think the microphone might
have something to do with it,
so I'm going to ditch this,
and then just go ask people.
So let's see what happens.
Excuse me, I have a quick question.
Do you have one second?
I don't have Thanksgiving plans,
would you let someone like me come?
- No, I'm so sorry.
- I'm flying home tomorrow.
- I'm from Las Vegas.
- We're not hosting so
it's not our choice.
- Would they be weirded out if I came?
- I think so.
- Yeah.
Of course, I'm sorry to bother you.
Excuse me, I have a question.
Would you be okay with me
joining your Thanksgiving dinner?
- Yeah?
- Sure!
- I'm actually filming
a video for BuzzFeed,
and I'm wondering, would
you mind coming to talk
to me about it real quick?
- Sure!
I want everyone to feel like they've got
a place to stay for Thanksgiving,
and have a sense of family,
even if they don't have family nearby.
- I feel all warm and fuzzy inside.
This is great, you guys are great people.
- Thanks.
- Thank you!
- Love makes the world go round.
- Happy Thanksgiving!
- Please.
- Okay, we have to do this together.
- Okay, ready?
You lead.
♫ Thanksgiving is tomorrow
♫ And we're all gonna spend it together
♫ I should have started this song
♫ I would have done much better
- That was good!
♫ But Happy Thanksgiving to all
- That was nice, that was good!
- Yeah, I enjoyed it.